you can always buy alcohol and you don't
need a membership for that
[Music]
hi my name is oscar and i'm a former
employee at costco for three years hi my
name is oscar with bin s not a z and i'm
a former costco employee of about five
and a half years my name is sequoia and
i'm a current costco employee of about
14 years a manager of about five years
and today we're going to share some tips
and tricks on how to be a better shopper
tip number one the best time to shop at
costco would be early afternoon or early
evening between like six and seven if
you go in the morning it's always full
of these like hordes of zombies just
waiting for the store to slowly open and
make it impossible to shop in go
midday because everyone's at work or
they're busy picking up kids from school
so anytime between 11 to 1 pm i would
suggest you guys go around that time as
well
tip number two you can use your
membership anywhere in the world mexico
china australia anywhere there is a
costco and your current costco member
you're able to use your costco card
tip number three costco business centers
are not just for business owners the
benefit of the business centers are
their hours you can shop as early as 7
00 a.m roughly to about 6 p.m especially
during the pandemic it's always good to
shop early and they always open up
earlier than the regular costco
warehouses they're full of less people
and they have better snacks than the
other costco's tip number four you can
return nearly anything at costco
be mindful that nothing is meant to be a
lifetime warranty there are certain
exceptions also in regards to our 90-day
return policy for electronics and things
of that sort when i was working at
costco i remember people returning happy
and chickens half a case of water
because it tasted funny and for me that
means if i have produce that goes bad
right away i take it back and just get a
fresh one
yeah you can return perishables
tip number five items are constantly
being moved around oh my goodness i know
that it is extremely frustrating you
come in you see an item in a certain
place you come in the next day and it
has been moved i get it it's extremely
frustrating for us as employees as well
costco has this treasure hunt mentality
where basically they like to move things
around the store have customers look
around for them so that way they're
exploring the store and the merchandise
and as an employee that was the most
annoying thing because when a customer
comes up to you it asks you hey where
can i find this it might be in the same
place you thought it was yesterday or
you know what it might be on the other
side of the warehouse so it's kind of
annoying as an employee having to always
have to move the whole warehouse around
in products
tip number six items at costco aren't
always cheaper than they are at
retailers like for example markets
usually like mark down produce if
they're not in season or they're running
out but at costco everything stays the
same price when it comes to that we also
have additional services that are
available for all of our members from
auto buying rental cars water delivery
most people don't know about those
things so dig deep and trust me it's
worth it tip number seven if you buy an
item before it goes on sale you can go
back to costco within 30 days and get a
price adjustment costco is really
looking out for you the customer they
want to make sure that you're happy at
the end of the day so you don't have to
worry if you buy something and you see
that it goes on sale you can always take
your receipt back and get the refund tip
number eight if you hear a bell go off
in the deli it means a new batch of
chicken is coming out rotisserie
chickens are one of our most popular
items they're amazing you can smell them
fresh as soon as you walk in nearly i
feel like it's costco culture to like
eat the rotisserie chicken just because
it's so good super popular super
delicious juicy flavorful i advise you
to check it out
tip number nine if you see a price that
ends in 97 it's something that has been
marked down because it didn't do well
and the customer is getting the best
price possible at that point so if you
see a 97 buy it because that is the best
price that you will find
tip number 10 if the price ends in 0-0
or 88 cents it means that it's a manager
special although it's a good deal be
sure to look them over before you pick
it up because you don't know if it might
be returned or it might be damaged and
that can happen in various ways
tip number eleven if there's an asterisk
on the price tag it means the item won't
be coming back this applies a lot to
seasonal items whether it's like
halloween time or thanksgiving time you
usually find a lot of decorations that
have an asterisk because they're only
seasonal so just make sure that you keep
an eye out for that because then that
means that we won't be restocking it
again
tip number 12 almost everything goes on
sale eventually so if you don't see
something you're looking for just hang
tight it'll typically come up on another
coupon miller just be patient
tip number 13 the farther you walk into
the store the better deals you'll find
if you notice at every costco their
best-selling item toilet paper is in the
back of the store that way it gets all
the customers from the front of the
store to the back to explore everything
that's going on what you want to do is
avoid the front because it actually has
the highest markups but the further and
further you go into the store or the
center of the store you'll see some of
our seasonal promotions and things like
that
tip number 14 if you don't have a
membership there are still things you
can do and buy for example you can
always buy alcohol and you don't need a
membership for that which is always
great for those college students who
can't afford a card just go there buy
your alcohol call it a day also just a
tip if you don't have a membership of
want to go buy other things you can have
someone buy you a costco gift card and
you can use that to shop in the store
until it runs out tip number 15
technically the samples are unlimited
costco encourages all of the vendors to
give samples or as many as they want
what you don't want to do is upset the
little old ladies that are giving you
these samples so just be mindful of the
people around you we love for you to try
the items before you buy it costco wants
you to be completely satisfied tip
number 16 some shoppers are actually
undercover security agents looking out
for people trying to commit staff or
trying to damage the warehouse in some
shape or form so just one person comes
in dressed up as a normal person walks
around they actually look a little bit
shady half of the time because you just
see them like casually like looking at
the items and then looking over at
people they don't do a very good job at
it because i can always spot them out
whenever i go to a costco so if you're
walking with your car the person next to
you might be a secret shopper it might
be on to you if you're trying to steal
something so don't steal
thanks for watching i hope these tips
and secrets will help you be a better
shopper at costco when you're not trying
to kill each other over toilet paper i'm
like i'm not gonna wake up and stand in
line for two hours to buy toilet paper
like this is ridiculous
[Music]
you